thank you to Rocky money and hello fresh for
sponsoring this video more on them after the
reaction [Music] peeps how's it going there
citizens of the reject Nation or should I say
citizens of the reject Nation it's your boy
John here once again doing more Sanders baby
we've been working through some of the classics
now we're going to hop forward about 10 years
in time to the mid 2000s today we're going to
watch click a movie on know little to nothing
about other than it maybe shares a premise with
a Goosebumps episode I saw at one point in time
but anyway that's beside the point uh I'm
enjoying this man like you know like I said
how have you missed all these movies we weren't
in Adam Sandler house growing up we weren't a
Jim Carrey house either so that's afforded me
this opportunity to catch up on some of these
and I got to say for whatever aversions I might
have had in the past I'm quite enjoying this now
so uh thank you guys for watching leave a like
for going back in time or or getting timey wiy
at all as I understand this movie might and
as always be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification Bell so that you're notified anytime
one of these videos comes your way also big thank
you to the folks over at prepper for chopping
down these highlights helping us out on that
end it's a big task and we appreciate them
for it also if you want to get the complete
click experience in the comfort of your own home
where you can click your own remote and actually
probably mess it up cuz you have to sync it up
with your own copy but any way you can do that
over at patreon.com theal rejects we also have
a bunch of other shows and movies with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included that Greg
and I cover over there it's a good time it's
a blast come check it out te's like these are
available at reject naations shop.com it's one
of the best ways to support the channel and now
without further Ado let's watch the shoe movie
Click [Music]
Howard the Duck Sandler also loves his 80s
hits Twinkies helped to pay for
this architectural Graphics huh is that a subtle
detail of his character oh oh no what was going
on you were sleeping daddy how can I sleep with
two twinky she's so cute which one of these turns
on a TV oh my God I had a we had a garage clicker
just like that at the old place so many things to
click honey I think you just
open the garage the K beckon
sale whatever happened to the good old days
when you pulled a knob and on came the the old
Do's got a universal remote control one clicker
controls everything makes life a lot easier for
old people like you after you figure out the
complicated ass controls do you think you'll
have time to finish building the treeh house ever
a it's kind of been halfway done for 2 months now
get it together dad I got a lot of things going
on at work right now but as soon as I'm done I'm
on it I promise I got poor time management skills
but I'm on it look at Su is duck oh oh no that's
not wrestling that's less than 5 minutes in man
something you should know about for another 10
to 30 years 10 for you 30 for you well you know
by the time they hit fourth grade they got the
Discovery Channel don't they we ain't nothing but
mammals well some of us cannibals who cut other
people open like antelopes I'll see you tonight
at the swim me swim I'll be there okay all right
I love you Michael forever and ever Babe a Mr
Newman Kevin yeah always a pleasure what kind
of stereo you got in that blue piece of [__] my
father's stereo is a bow your father stereo blows
that's too bad oh I wonder if Bose paid for that
one or if that was just a stray because of the
joke morning Mr hi morning brands have become a
lot more Savvy with comedy you know in the past 10
20 years stuck in traffic for an hour and a half
when's the meeting it started already oh no can I
go to the bathroom go to the bathroom I told you
that you don't have to ask me jeez so Manhattan
will allow us Michael hassle in the hu more on
in a red Lamborghini Park than my spot so Prince
habibu Drive red Lamborghini oh my God is that Rob
Schneider in a makeup Prince Habi habibu habibu I
thought I said that when Mr Amer explained to
me the type of man you are who prides himself
on originality a disruptor yes I present to you
your restaurant where is where is bar here's the
bar now the waterfall he is an architect okay
make bar longer okay oh boy cut into the atrium
a little bit no Atrium just make bar longer for
Prince habibu really man of very particular taste
water's got to go someplace Michael let's just
take out the atrium and run with that whoa this
simply awesome so you want me to design you an
Arabian hoochie house how dare you compare Prince
obu's bikini Hut restaurant to this hoie house
bikini Hut restaurant Prince habib's Mojo Dojo
Casa house Prince Hab habba nowing oh my God what
are the ethics of that scene see that uh parking
garage over there on 56 I build that with my bare
hands wants to knock it down and build a luxury
hotel you got the commission not yet I just
need someone to come up with a design proposal
intrigued an interesting cut to that shot
intrigued I'm Fourth of July and with the
kids this weekend right when I get back
I'm all over it I'll put schwartzon on it
no no absolutely not Nick schwartzon can't it
just wait 3 days I CU these guys are Japanese
I can't wait for their fish to [Music] cook
that's why we have sushi impatience see you
later for drinks at happy hour with Prince
ababi my son has a swim meet tonight that
I have to get to uh it's one of the go be
with your kids Christopher Robin life is
more than just business Corp all the [Music]
time what I play they play The Offspring for
like a big bad version that's great great you're
not my dad oh no far as you know what really my
dad that was a great delivery from that kid oh
what do you have wikler you just got here Dad I
saw you I mean I just got here why are you saying
that I was I saw you you jumped in over there you
swed here then what stroke was he doing Dad he
was doing the shut up the shut up good thing
is Daddy was here to see you finish he didn't
see me finish he was hanging out with pink Boo
for some reason yeah what was that a there kid
was drowning I'm going to let him drown goes
drown into my shot Aon too Bill hle Ben swim
coach must be dad Michael speed up Michael
Norman sorry don't you lose that Speedo Sam gamg
remember right arm out head turns left left arm
out head turns right I just the you master
that with your power people going to think
you're half a dolphin out there really yeah
he did have a swaave kind of charm that Sean
Aston oh it's not a race that's a second one
in 5 minutes give me some of them sprinks boy
sprinkle top tier yogurt ice cream topping
everything Michael's been doing lately is
very unhealthy for him he's going to kill
himself Oh no just working himself into
the ground oh Jesus scared the crap out of me
me too Dad how much longer are you going to
live I'm going to live for 200 years is that
long enough for you and me promise I promise
swear come here I would love if this movie
turns into being about that how can I live
for 200 years show us some respect you piece
of a [__] go home and watch VH1 old man go
home and watch VH1 what an insult what a burn
what am I holding a quarter Grandma does not
let me eat ice cream because of my diabetes
oh no she says nothing however about a tasty
qu about some delicious magic whoa please count
to three cuz it taste terrible one 1 2 3 oh how
would you do that Grandpa a good magician never
Reveals His secret of course not your daddy has
wanted to know how I've done that trick since
he was your age isn't that true son yeah yeah
yeah sure in a minute Michael who you talking
to I'm talking to my boss M take it easy even
he's got ice cream it's going to be soup now dude
comment below what's your favorite ice cream and/
or yogurt topping the goat of all autal leave
it down below you done can we relax now sorry
oh my God every time oh [__] you better run who
I hate that that jump was kind of crazy did he do
that wait for this guy Pocahontas no back to bed
Pocahontas is up we can paint with all the colors
of the wind tomorrow I have an idea for a pocah
I feel like that's one movie you could reboot
live action you'd have to change some [__] but
it could work besides all the Woodland creatures
will laugh at you if you collapse trying to put
up the tent this weekend yeah I forgot to tell
you we had a postpone the camping trip no we have
to postpone grown-ups too it's due Tuesday if I
don't finish the designs I'm off it so but the
kids have been talking about camping with you
all year it's just every choice I make every I
do I disappoint somebody oh I feel that maybe
make sure you don't keep disappointing the wrong
people also fair I'm working my ass off so my
family can have a better life than I ever dreamed
of having when I was a kid the only way for that
to happen is for me to watch this sing show so
relax hun jeez jeez are you kidding me will you
give me a break one time the odo's got a stin in
universal remote control we're going to have one
too so it's an interesting way they have thread
that particular you know piece of the plot into
this feels very tangental but also charmingly
so like it reminds me of all the gadgets and
Gremlins but if that didn't actually have much
sense Beyond just being there in the first
place bath be on it is all of a sudden
I just want to go to bed bath and get
some Wendy's fries you guys got any universal
remote controls in there for a shower curtain
or a bath mat maybe for a blanket you got a
remote for a blanket I'm sorry dude I don't
even work here I'm just waiting for my
friend wow uh actually yeah yes I don't
have any friends will you be my friend
what the hell is happening what an like
Nick swartson has had such an odd career I
feel like but you know Adam Sandler looks
out for his buds so tired of my life oh I'm
calling it there he fell asleep this is all a
dream don't even get me
started on that Beyond section
bed bath must have paid for this too but
this is but I do love that this is the
choice
hey sorry to sneak up on you I just you guys got
a universal remote control back here go do the
Fat Boy Slim dance go do weapon of choice you're
looking for a universal remote control yeah just
one device to do it all for me make my life a
little easier quicker not so damn complicated
it's like the thesis statement of the future I'm
going to show you a remote we just got in that's
probably the most advanced piece of technology we
have in this place whoa sounds sweet it is sweet
the latest greatest universal remote not even on
the market yet Morty got this crazy new remote
Morty we got to watch a lot of TV we got to we got
to flip all the Channel all all the channels Morty
come in the back with me okay sorry his name tags
is Morty it's either that or a bad Chris walking
impression about to rock your world yes let's
[Music]
go I got to be honest with this place looks
bigger from the outside just kidding bed bath and
Tardis really new stuff I love the Beyond
section I think maybe there in the
middle he's got great mannerisms in
this sneaky sneaky sneaky where's
the Box does it come with directions not necessary
point he's always got the dance in him how much
she just think cuz I ain't exactly thirst and
how you know it's not in the B Code system
the B Code system I'm going to have to just
give it to you you want me to take my shirt
off for you something cuz I don't play for
that team no just drop it why are you doing
this then good guys need a break every once
in a while okay you're like the T you're
like Don knots in Pleasantville right now
why don't you take this remote instead got
a little more o f only one thing you need
to know mhm this item is not returnable why
would I want to return something I got for
free that's a fair point as they
exit the warehouse from Indiana
Jones get that scissor sipping on some lean
twinky you don't need it you don't need it man
you do need a Yoda though you do need to name
each of the reputable Brands Under the twinky
Umbrella hey welcome to AR my own TV on freaking
whiz good I guess it's supposed to speak to his
disorganization is he just neurode Divergent yeah
can I ask you something I mean after you do all
this work and become a big player at your company
would you really think you're going to have any
more time for us or are things just going to get
even more out of control that is the fairest Quest
first thing I'm going to do is hire a bunch of
idiots just like me to do all my work so then
you me and the kids can do whatever the hell we
want just got to give me some time don't give
me that look just saying give me some support
sure go to sleep just think about it Michael
a hey hey hey keep it down dude everybody's
sleeping ah somethings off with that remote
you got to poop again won you do
the humpy pumpy on the duck okay
you just hold it in for 5 minutes
and keep the freaking volume down
oh yes I love that he instinctually
grabbed that and went for the [Music]
volume that remote does look a little like
a pleasure wand I'm just going to say it
when you combine mass quantities
of cough syrup with yodel you get
acid sure let's go with that let's
go with that theory hey you said you
got to go go already man all right I'm
going I'm going sniffy long droppings
today sniffy I I'll give it to you
sniffy long droppings is is a good
one that sound effect
Jesus of all the dogs I've ever met I think
I've seen one hump something I've been a lot
of dogs in my life right in the short run
plastic surgery is a hassle but hey Jennifer
coolage too face and a body that's going to get
me to places where I want to be sure it's going
to get you to the White Lotus I just think
you know they're too Slavic oh my God morning
Michael you're looking very crappy today you're
looking very Slavic oh no don't say that you're
just jealous cuz Don and I are going to the gym
all the guys are going to be hitting on [Music]
us I haven't heard the in a long time I love
oh my God I want that so bad a husband that
I can kiss and love and and give juice
to oh you got the juice you've already
cheated on three different husbands with
their brothers you've given enough juice
to everybody next time you fall in love marry
their brother instead all of my husbands all
of them have emotionally abandoned me
that is a drip though that jumpsuit I
had a rabbit named Peppa and that rabbit
abandoned me too you a rabbit oh [Music]
no oh no you're
Great's picture in picture oh my God the problem
is there'll be contacts or brain implants to let
you do this later on good Robo dog and he can
bark in over six different languages yeah it's
much cooler than your stupid human dog a see
ke's new robot dog Sundance what the do very
nice very nice very nice it's worth more
than your car wow not anymore a dog okay
now that that kid's dad's going to come beat
the [__] out of you this is some sort of
reality show are you the host where are the
cameras oh all right America have you glasses
look like ikabog Crane and sleepy Hol wanted a
universal remote control that remote controls
your Universe just hit menu on the remote
no the menu with the Red Lobster yes on the
remote a lot of Red Lobster shout outs and
Adam Sandler movies too wow welcome to the
construct what is this your life menu My
Life as a commentary yes let's go who's
on it click it click it like the title this
is last Tuesday Michael was eagerly awaiting
the arrival of his lunch order who's that James
was going to say recognize that voice instantly
Alice had brought him a cheeseburger instead of
a hamburger as he requested it's from a totally
different part of Germany it was either going to
be James Earl Jones or Sam or uh uh Morgan freem
Sam Jackson would be fun but you no he can hey
psychedelic where are we oh good oh my God you
are literally within your mind Palace spank bank
they're making you like bunny rabbit oh you can
access this I can't see what happened are you
before time feels good on my feet check it out
you hit the fast forward button I believe was some
time add to your conception wow oh my God where my
mother it's a girl I have no idea what we're
going to do with that scene when it comes to
YouTube sorry it might be a boy what do you mean
might be what is that wait a minute maybe that's
a that's a that's my can I see that h that's
a tiny schmeckle think of a time in a place
hit rewind and you're there um Place ooh all
right we're going to have a lot of long lenses
long takes everything's going to feel a little
docu style Michael dinner's almost ready invite
your friends if you want to a and if you want
to come by my tent for some supper or we need
at my family's wi bag and please company
a some camping trip why can't we camp in
an arv like every other family how can you
get close to Nature in a tin can like that
plus it's more fun to have to keep each other
warm at night don't you know no cupcakes yet
but I'm starving you know how hungry I am
I am so hungry I could eat this oh here we
go how the heck did he do the the trick coin
you buy in a magic shop a just couldn't let
him know I knew that oh no that's a bummer
actually that's going to come back later
it's a very powerful device use it with
caution yeah who are you you know who
I am God if you have any questions call
me no Linda ammer what the what this is
a Tarantino movie now this hotel project is a
big fish you reel it in for me and it's a Audy
partner Denise just called she's got to
go to rehab again so she can't make it
to the Hamptons Mr Amer if you need female
companionship this weekend my wife's friend
Janine wow you guys should go to the
beach together what she like Wow Let's
just say uh she will eat you up Sir oh my
God those eyebrows that grin it's kind of
important okay what go to the bathroom this
movie has some very interesting recurring
jokes dud you suck so bad do not hey Dad
a buddy playing some catch actually we're
playing some drop cuz Ben hasn't caught
one yet you're truly your Father's son
hey you're a regular Derek cheer yourself o
doy love you kid love you too Dad a loving
child abuse your parents they should come
for dinner that sounds good that' be fun
for them to be here for the sleepover God man
it's not going to kill you to eat dinner with
your family sweetie I know I just got to
build an entire model tonight man I get it
but also your emotions are incredibly crushed
down this is like Raising Arizona right now
whoa I can skip chapters how does this account
for you all right let's get dinner over with
next next oh no alone in my basement at last
should I do my work and become partner now I
think so are you fully removed from the fatigue
of having lived through all those I have so many
questions can you watch the gang for 10 minutes
while I clean up can't you I just I got so much
stuff to do here G I'm not asking for like a
whole day you don't have to do that much how
can deal with [Music] that H this is going to be
bad dude also Everybody Wants to Rule the World
skip the whole not every single oh I skipped the
whole fight ouch I can't sleep you can't a don't
be upset okay I was a jerk mhm you are a jerk I
mean you are kind of a jerk jerk you got a lot
of pressure on you but you're kind of a jerk dude
stop it sleep over catch us they ain't going to
hear us come on okay quietly TR Co me in a I got
to get back to work can't we just oh dude it's the
same stuff just think of last time and you that
get into it man lose yourself in the moment this
time you can be sance and I'll be the duck yeah
but you got to massage me first I love giving
massages you should dog come on massaging
away here no no you need a therapy remote
dude wow [Music] w we did it well you did oh dude
come yeah I'll get you next time thanks why have
the hottest people in the world be your wife if
this is how you're going to behave man so we go
for tomorrow you said we could go to lunch
tomorrow and Pikachu dad's birthday gift of
course I I said so so I'll be there need another
massage go away okay no yeah can I talk to you
for a minute isn't Michael Newman like a new
wave musician or something no that's Gary new
Hello whoa where' you come from you don't want
to know his delivery throughout this is like
Peak walking but it's it's it's poetry it's
like a dance it must have been an autopilot
that's what happens to you when you fast forward
okay yeah I'll show you oh sure good he's here
for me the remote lets your mind skip around
but your body actually stays put for all the
boring stuff Hy we should go to lunch tomorrow
got your dead birthday again sounds good I'm
having conversations on autopilot then you're
not going to be the life of the py but yes M
your wife absolutely gorgeous perfect face tight
rocking body I wish Christopher Walkin say that
about me she felt for a schlub like you sometimes
it's better to keep certain memories just in your
head so I've learned Morty good night thank you
I don't know which I would have preferred like
a bunch of stereotypically hot Adam Sandler
you know partner girls or you know what we
got here it's Monday already are you kidding
me no more FL ski an entire cold what I don't
remember doing any work this weekend yeah oh yeah
this going to do to your sweetie there's no hot
water I got to take a shower well you're going to
freeze your bum off boil some some water in the
stove don't worry dude you're going to get
that like anti-inflammatory look at me oh
showered and dress and looking sexy oh boy
you going to have to work late again tonight
unfortunately yes is there anything we can
do to help well I'm going to be partnered
soon and I'm going to need a lot of new
building designs so if you guys have any
cool ideas why don't you draw them up for me a
they're going to design some cool imaginative
building they're going to be building by
the very end of the [Music] [Applause]
movie everyone's looking at you no don't
mute Sergeant Jeffords traffic traffic no
more traffic no Terry yeah that's what I'm
talking about baby you look a little pale
there pal let me fix that oh no you now
all yellow from the scurvy captain now
you're just in a Michael Bay movie now don't
get the Hulk angry that's it check out Julio
e glacius Julio glaas wait a minute refresh
me chat comments it's actually pretty good
man where'd you find the time to get a t uh I
guess I can do it all sir you can do it all wow
it's sexual harassment speech Day speech day
anyone can be a victim of sexual harassment
a woman a man what is going to happen here you
see what is sh here like the day I said you want
a promotion pray God the lotion hilarious
sexual harassment if you ask me of course
something public
bathroom did they get like I know they're
like famous voice actors in various parts
of the world so did they get like Adam
Sandler and Hasselhoff's like voiceovers
for Spanish language to do that itro
is the greatest of all time the goat
you can always count on Matsui well if you
guys love Ichiro and Matsui so much let's
order them both hey see you guys in a bit
each your own Match away baseball players
yes oh yeah you can translate these morons are
so boring they make me want to take a sword and
chop my own off wow Hotel design like to rip it
up think that Egghead watched a bed documentary
on Asian architecture uhoh the lobby let's
build more rooms and maximize profs eat as
fast as you can then we can get out of here and
do jell shots at America's greatest cultural
achievement TGI Friday TG Fridays I realize this
is not what you're all about let's just throw it
out all right start from scratch River in the
lobby idea what an egghead move forget all the
niceties and maximize our Revenue that's what
it's all about anyway oh now you're speaking
our everyone's language that way we can get
the hell out of this dump go to a TGI Friday
do some jello shots to this guy pukes up a l
yeah smooth sailan from here on out oh I got
your presents what is it what is it well if you
bring your tushies downstairs we'll find out oh
my goodness it's almost Charming the the grand
degree of branded references and and product
placed you know props and things there are
it's just part of an Adam Sandler movie to
me [Music] now a real Huff bike take them outside
wait theor let him see what you got ouch ride it
through their living room wreck their carpets and
scribble on their walls oh Michael it's beautiful
a a what are we celebrating we're healthy we
got a great family are we healthy I'm am's
newest partner you're going to have like a heart
attack with all those cakes that you eat that's
incredible I knew it was going to be a great day
today I heard her song on the radio this morning
a the song that was playing during our first kiss
oh oh no oh no of course I know our song our song
is wow I remember this place oh Wolverine's
goofy cousin it's kind of a nice look though
I like it oh my goodness look at you you're out
of his League aren't you look at those earrings
yo first kiss time oh what's going to happen you
got an answer to that a and I love how the song
just kind of floats in all she's thinking about
is I am not kissing that beard [Music] a I'm
such a fool for you The Cranberries was playing
during our first juicy kiss and my God you look
beautiful in that pink sweat are you wearing a oh
you really knocked one out of the park last night
didn't you hey you were great too all you got to
do now is draw up the construction plans if wat
commits to the major bulk of the funds looking
at my new partner Oh I thought I was already
your partner whoa Cowboy yeah I said land the
wat sahita account you'll get promoted I didn't
mean right this second to do these documents it's
going to take me months and you better get started
oh wow I just got a big headache I hung out with
your friend Janine this weekend I hope she's doing
your brother right now you bigheaded buffoon oh
my God what are you doing here what are you doing
here wow that last one came out
that last one came out in your
Brites dude no anyway the you get
it back to pardner rise I taste
[__] consider the consequences of the thing
you're thinking about doing what are you saying
I shouldn't do it it's your life you do with the
remote decision Micha oh we're talking a couple
of months here I fast forward through it what am
I going to miss uh 30 arguments in a haircut a m
the leprechaun oh one from the cereal Ed lucky
never gets his Lucky Charms they're magically
delicious de kids are always messing with them
was chasing the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow but when it gets there it's just corn
flakes and marshmallows you don't understand
the metaphor I won't do it all right oh boy nah
you still don't understand the metaphor though
Dad yeah we have some designs for you maybe
they'll help you finish quicker all right you
want me to look at it oh no oh no ceilings too
high the hallways too narrow stairway placement
makes no sense at all what the hell is this room
made it Pizza yes no I want a pizza room he's 7
years old if he wants a playroom made of pizza
then why not maybe he's got to grow up sometime
and get the hell off Fantasy Island the plane
the plane he make your partner today oh honey
I'm so sorry she's the most understanding person
forward me to my promotion fast forward to the
promotion the greatest partner I could ever dream
of thank you guys oh you guys have been dating a
couple of months now that's pretty huge for this
one a now the first few months were easy it was
the one year hump that was the tough part oh yeah
hey hi how's he doing for you and Donna what do
you mean you know what sweetie it's none of our
business let's let Michael bask in his glory oh
yeah yeah you knew this was coming no no I want
to I want to it's I'm I'm on autopilot I'm on
autopilot you like Auto Zombie yeah what do you
want from me this is what happens oh my God he's
going to answer his phone what the heck happened I
didn't even touch the remote great you're going to
startop watching TV at dinner now M I'm not going
to work tonight we're going to watch Dragon Tales
together what do you say Dragon Tales is for
babies dad I want to watch CSI but which CSI
like whoa hey better destroy that dog and get your
Twinkie back give me my twinkie get back here you
freaking Gremlin ah Gremlins great movie where
Sundance don't mention Sundance the kids just
stop crying oh he died no oh no Daddy held it in
so long he was your best dog he's finally letting
himself feel [Laughter] it he tried to hump my leg
and I didn't let him and I should I'm sorry it's
okay let it out you do you still love me I don't
know to stay with me my God it didn't take the
duck long to get over Sundance uh deviant but it's
kind of turning me on oh my no [Music] no no my
God no no it's not my fault it jumped on its own I
didn't even hit the button not even close oh no oh
no
[Laughter] this thing is broken it's just
it's fast forward and on its own now it's
not a malfunction it's a feature using
its memory to execute your preferences
advanced piece of equipment like to yes
sir oh it is it's going to do it on its
own now pretty much no more showering no
more traffic no more arguing no sickness
this bad oh yeah deactivating my service
I qu I he said you can't return it no
[Music] whoa nice get away is
this a stickup or are you just
happy this item is non returnable sure how do
I get it to just stop fast forwarding you got
to you got to can you like break through it you
want to shower first no I can't shower because
then I'll fast forward and if I fast forward
who knows how long I'll fast forward for let
me just uh how's this I'm going to R it today uh
and we can't argue because off I'll go so I just
know there is a problem I tried to get rid of
the problem last night and it almost ended up
in my ass so wa I can't give you a kiss because
if I give you a kiss it might lead to something
else and then zip another 3 minutes goes by
laying there disappointed and I'm laying there
like an idiot smiling so I oh my [Music] God a
pretty solid soundtrack on this movie man and
we're in New York it's perfect place for The
Strokes your first day as a partner you come
to work in a freaking bathrobe I just feel we
should stop wasting our energy on corporate
Brown noosing and worrying who's got the better
suit armman Calvin Klein who cares ex shell white
but God damn it you're right of course you are
there's something or actually someone I'd like
to talk to you about Janine oh Janine and I have
decided to drop out of the Rat Race slow down and
move to Morocco wow Eric Lamona will assume my
day-to-day responsibilities and I'd like you to
take his job you know I wouldn't be surprised if
one day you ended up being our CEO if you could
just get your [__] together but no no no no
I don't want a promotion no oh oh Michael you
have a phone call wow where that big guy wow told
me you wanted to be CEO Eric LOF killed himself
oh I mean you do got to do something
about your diet man I love sweets as
much as the next person but things
good oh yeah there is some CG and
some makeup and possibly a a whole
different body double happening
here oh my God I'm a fat guy look at me it's
okay oh no not the sounds not the squirmy
jiggle sounds this is 1010 winds news February
5th 2017 things don't click oh my can I help
you hey whoa Jonah Hill look how big you got
you're enormous ouch maybe if you would take
me like to Pilates like you said you would people
wouldn't think I was Rosie o'donell ouch it is so
embarrassing whoa and you get your ass upstairs
you put some normal clothes on why are you so
mean to me get him on just let her be Js from
Arcane you I'm so scared knock knock gang hey
uhoh oh no Sean Aston oh I forgot about sha
Aston he had to come back back you cheating
on me with Johnny g string over here I thought
we were past all that no no no we'll past this
all that oh just you don't mess with another
man right you don't mess with yeah you scking
up for him go away gote you oh my God this is
a nightmare I hate [Music] you no and you never
ever finish the That's right The Treehouse 10
years you're not finished yet Mor you did this
to yourself Michael no you did this to yourself
Michael the remote goes by your behavior every
time you had a conflict between work and
home work one yeah you can't change what
already happened but you're still a young man
you could win on a back so that's what I'll do
wow ow yeah please just read
my note I hate you I hate
you
yeah Michael are you awake Michael honey oh
where did all my fat go is he an Oldman I mean
he doesn't look that old did a fuzzy dog push me
over oh Shaggy the miracle dog yeah if he hadn't
knocked you on your nogin you wouldn't have had
the CAT scan that found the cancer before it
spread too far wow you had cancer you're the only
person in the world to gain weight during chemo
that's probably what caused your heart attack
what what since the head injury you haven't
been healthy a full day when exactly did I hurt my
head six years ago six more years no no it skipped
all my sickness Bill's waiting for me downstairs
Bill a Bill's my husband please learn to accept
that I really have to go husbando Dad hey how you
feeling whoa my old office what what are we doing
here the architect how did this happen where's
your pizza room oh wait that's a blondie chesty
what check check and check no that's your daughter
Samantha of course it is always take care of her
and make sure nobody touches her make sure that
her emotional needs are met and the she's cared
for like to spend more time together all of
us take you out for ice cream how's that you
Samantha Grandpa Grandma oh need to go pop drink
this all right drink some water are Grandma and
Grandpa gone Grandpa died dad oh yeah yeah oh no
where was I you crying what happened oh you know
he just got old that's life [Music] oh man I got
to go hey hang on Susie push my next meeting I'll
do your meeting it's fine I'm just dizzy dizzy
from the operation you're going to make me cry dad
a yeah it won't take you there take me where to
the moment he died you weren't there can you take
me to the last time I saw him please oh boy boy
would you mind looking at my uh my shopping mall
design again if you check this out it's got a
pizza room let me do my email yeah you're right
Dad um he ain't right you're a schmuck surprise
whoa theyve had him in younger and older make up
this movie when did you get so handsome oh
no is this going to be like an ugly moment
your mother's playing Canter with her friends
tonight I thought oh what a great opportunity
you me and Ben should go and have a boys night
out K oh you have to eat sometime we could go
we could whistle at pretty girls hey please
don't give me that finger runs in the family
I'll make you deal if you come oh no yeah I'll
show you the qu you knew this was coming don't
you want to know you do the stupid trick I've
always known can you let me do my work yeah I'm
so sorry I parched in oh see you later grandpa
I love you it's SC Avengers [Music] table oh
dude oh he's yeah take your opportunity
I love you son yeah I love you too
death that's actually a really Surly touching
moment h that's that's sweet I'm sorry about your
father taking him wasn't something I wanted to
do oh what's that what do you mean taking
him an angel M okay of course I thought an
angel's supposed to protect people I'm the
angel of death woooo that shot your dad is
time oh my God we got
Scrooged all right leave me alone leave
me alone you have your fun just take me
to a good place oh take me to the good
place cuz you know you're going to the
bad place right now it's time for Mr Newman
to say a few words cheeu Christ day wedding
cake okay where's the groom hi there wow this
is terrific buddy who's the lucky lady very
funny Mr Newman God the drips at this party oh
congratulations let's have the best night okay
a Michael you haven't kissed me like that since
you were a little boy you were the best M A why
didn't you say it soona you've been so generous
taking care of all this in the kids honeymoon
absolutely thank you here's one you might remember
from The Cranberries oh no oh no what's it called
linger Bill since it's our son's wedding do
you mind if I dance with my ex-husband for a
minute yeah it's a Mana hey what are you doing
put a sweater on covered them up jeez it's not
used to seeing y'all growing up like this okay
well if that's your way of telling me that I
look pretty then thank you doing all the work
there I raise you there dad come yeah do that
stretch Zoom oh no your [Music] heart okay it
looks like alucino almost one dance you pop a
artery why did you make me waste my entire life
nah don't pass the buck live the life you chose
big shot yeah this is not the life I want looks
like it is oh my God she said she wouldn't leave
the hospital until you woke up why' you do
that or my father Oh I thought bill was your
father I have two fathers it's like that book
they took out of the school library I've got
two dance and I got a plane to catch going I
have to leave he needs his wa guys this all h
g who this spongebath going on over
there it doesn't have to end now oo
did you design this [Music] facility
future cars I do appreciate how much
they committed to this darker you know
ending act [Music] oh oh my God oh my
God the intensity of the shot [Music] oh
family family comes first family comes
first I love you I love you [Music] a is he
going to yeah of course till the very end
you're [Music] okay that's
very sweet forever and ever
[Music] Big [Music]
Damn yeah called it it it was in the visual
language I can't give myself too much credit
you're in bed bath and beyon next SW I'm back in
the store I'm young again I'm young you're kind
of on the back nine no ouch I'm just teeing
off baby yeah Happy Gilmore yeah you want a
friend this Spirits did it all in one night or the
angel my crappy car sequel to That's my boy that's
my crappy car dude where's my crappy car what's WR
I just want to tell you I love you I love you so
much you got to tell me how you do the quarter
trick please it's driving me crazy mag never
reveals the secrets come over tomorrow night and
the next night and the next night and the night
after that okay any you live with us now do you
mind I am trying to concentrate I mean here I am
staying up all night killing myself trying to come
up with activities for our fourth of July camp a
trip but you won't let me think oh you want time
to think why didn't you think about the fact you
just W what did you just say if you keep up this
weird attitude I won't be able to go to work for
a year and have to plan 10 more vacations that
make you happy did you eat a bad Yodo you know
what I'm going to finish the Treehouse and we're
going to sleep in it next weekend and from now
on we're going to exercise together and I'm not
going to wear a Speedo I'm not going to wear a
Speedo doggy ears go by very quick so it's time to
enjoy the real thing wow wow interesting but but
sure a no they told me at the pet store
was a female what did they do on sets to
to to get dogs to do that uh no it's 4th
of July I'm going to celebrate with my
wife take my time massage her make sure she
is fully satisfied that's the spirit man ah
no burn it like I said good guys need a break
I know you'll do the right thing this time oh
PS your wife's rocking body still drives me
crazy stay out of the astral plane above our
bedroom hey who wants to have a bill
fight and then HBO immediately said watch
something else wow oh nice and the New
Radicals needle drop for the very end the fun DVD
menu credits I like it I'm with it I'm I'm about
that it's good oh man guys first and foremost if
you're if you're joining me here and now and uh
you happen to be listening on Apple or Spotify
go ahead and rate this hopefully five stars but
you know whatever you feel uh just helps us you
know spread these round and grow the nation reject
um but yeah goodness I need a second this is a
fascinating experience this and uh and certainly
much more Broad and developed than the Goosebumps
I saw Sophie Monk that's her name okay yeah yeah
oh and rert Gregson Williams on the score a Rick
Baker did the special makeup effects okay not bad
not bad interesting well all right before we go
any further uh one thing you know is that this
this video certainly had a great many uh sponsors
this this movie you know had a lot of product
placements a lot of recognizable brand recognition
or that's that's repetitive but you get what I
mean and uh speaking of brand recognition there
are a couple people who made this video possible
and let's cut to them right now thank you to
America's number one meal kid hellofresh for
partnering with us it's always great to partner
with people Who services you actually use because
as someone like me who's always juggling a pack
schedule between filming and editing finding time
for healthy eating can be a challenge that's where
hellofresh has been a game changer for my life
with hellofresh I get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and delicious recipes delivered right
to my doorstep so I don't have to step outside
it's revolutionized my home cooking experience
making it not just easy but super enjoyable and
affordable keyw I recently tried their delicious
barbecue pineapple flat RADS and their zucchini
pomodora Panet bake both for mouth wateringly
delicious and fit perfectly with my pescatarian
lifestyle pescatarian s fancy and asking my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an incredible
variety tempts me to be a meat eater again people
I know I've really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you pronounce it
and the Fuego chicken fajo tacos regardless
hellofresh menu has something for everyone
but of course it's not just about the food it's
about saving time too not having a waight in
line at a grocery store even self checkouts on
fast enough these days the convenience of having
everything delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is Priceless especially with her quick and
easy meals like 15-minute recipes spending less
time in the kitchen and more time doing what I
love which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to support
the channel and also support you know having a
new lifestyle healthy affordable lifestyle in
the year 2024 go to hellofresh.com rejects free
and use code rejects free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast item
per box while the subscription is active free
breakfast for Life for hellofresh.com reex free
use promo code reject free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy and let's
keep enjoying those movies and shows all right
reject Nation let's get real for a moment running
this channel is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for the
channel and my personal life can be overwhelming
that's where rocket money has been a financial
Lifesaver for me even before I ever partnered
up with them like I said I've been very fortunate
to be working with Brands whose products I already
use so it's a win-win for him walk but it can be
a win-win for you too cuz there's a reason I use
them rocket money is a personal finance app that
simplifies managing money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and crafting a
budget that fits your specific lifestyle for
someone like me who can easily lose track of
expenses throughout every single day of the
month it's been eye openening to see where I was
overspending stuff I don't use that I kept paying
for especially apps man I was way too many apps
rocket money does the heavy lifting by analyzing
your spending then customizes notifications to
help you stay within your budget goals it's not
just about saving money it's about actively seeing
and feeling your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly subscriptions
too so many free trials I signed up for that I
forgot to you know get rid of before the free
trial was done making it super easy to cancel
the ones you don't use couple of clicks and you're
putting money back in your pocket telling you have
you ever found hidden subscriptions or pay for
services you forgot about because Rocky money is
a huge asset in helping to uncover those and even
negotiate some of my bills down to like 20% so if
you're ready to take control of your finances and
there's no better time than now because it is the
beginning of the year check out rocket money and
see how much you could be saving stop wasting
money on things you do not use so to help support
the channel and help support your wallet visit
rocket money.com / rejects rocket money currently
has over 5 million users and has helped save its
members an average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions they've helped
me and I'm confident they'll do the same for you
that's rocket money.com rejects your bank account
will thank you all right though that was super
fun I got to say you know I mean there there are
certainly elements of Adam Sandler's humor that
aren't you know necessarily 100% my flavor if I'm
just going for you know what I'm gravitated toward
but uh but I really enjoyed this experience and I
and I'd heard people say over the years that
it was you know like a surprisingly good one
or surprisingly affecting and I can definitely
see that here this got me a little misty-eyed at
a couple points especially toward the end um and
yeah it's like you know I was saying earlier this
this reminds me of of I think it was a Goosebumps
or or something I mean you know like the the idea
of a remote control that controls real life is
not you know the most crazy concept for a bunch
of people to arrive at independently but but
yeah like I I like what this made out of that
and the cautionary tale that this became and the
way that it is essentially like a scrooge Story
by the end of it you know you're seeing the error
of your way personified in the past in the present
in the future with slightly less of you know the
specific structure that that has but yeah you have
this otherworldly Spirit who shows up here and
there in Christopher Watkin who I really enjoyed
as like sort of the you know the lead not not
not lead supporting character cuz obviously you
have a bunch of other lead supporting character
characters who are more you know who share more
screen time who are like the prominent figures in
uh the Sandler characters life um but yeah having
him as this sort of main sort of um I don't know
this magical character existing on the periphery
popping up every now and again like I said it kind
of reminded me of like Don knots and Pleasantville
the the TV repair man but if he spent more time in
the movie uh than he does in that particular film
and yeah just like the way he brought his unique
walking uh I thought was really well pitched and
ATT tuned because obviously you get Christopher
Walkin when you want Christopher Walkin and in
this movie he's doing you know very much doing
his is walking his his timing it's specific and uh
and yeah he's doing he's leaning into his unique
Cadence and I think that yeah with the look that
they have him in he's just this perfect you know
um Midway point between this Whimsical sort of
impish figure and plausibly you know the spirit
of death is essentially and uh and I like that
that's what it became like I do appreciate when
a movie especially a movie like this any kind of
you know comedy that's going for a high concept
or something that does you know uh uh bring with
it sort of an innate cautionary tale of some
kind like I like when we can shift over into
you know seriousness when it's appropriate for
the story when it's appropriate for the action
and and I thought this managed to do that you know
obviously there are so many things and it's such
an enticing Concept in general there's so many
things that we would love to skip past in life
certainly like traffic being uh you know like the
the first rung of that ladders I think everybody
would be like man if I could just fast forward
the traffic experience like you know that'd be
great uh you know especially when you're sitting
you're not going anywhere like I like a drive but
you know you get what I mean and uh and yeah
coming in with the fun of the concept and you
know the promise of yeah idealizing your life by
skipping all the boring bits and getting right to
the good stuff or getting right to the thing
you've been anticipating it's something that
yeah would entice anybody I think or most people
but could easily go wrong and enhance your worst
qualities and I think that across the board they
did a nice job of of that you know at first like
the whole thing of getting to the remote and the
fact that they have like a billion remotes around
it did kind of feel like a a bit of a random
plot thread to get us there like a mechanic
specifically designed to get us there rather than
you know a real part of the story or part of the
characterization like the the the sweets and stuff
the the cakes and the Twinkies like that felt more
ingrained even though even still that kind of
felt like a like just a I don't know it could
have been anything like it it does come back and
there are elements of like oh man you know like
you're really unhealthy and you got fat or you
know you had heart attacks or whatever and you're
like it comes I think most into Focus as you know
a a real part of the you know array of of things
happening within the character when it turns out
that yeah like his son has grown up you know to
be a heavier set guy or whatever that is and and
you know that it's probably because of this mostly
cake and sweets based you know eating like it's
a miracle that the S of Sandler character and and
everyone around him doesn't have like diabetes or
something just because it seems like all he eats
are Twinkies uh but yeah yeah yeah having these
different elements kind of come together to inform
you know along with the obvious of he's really
dedicated to his work and he's always prioritizing
that over everything else and I thought they did
a nice job of drawing that portrait as well uh
because you know again there are a lot of things
that kind of recur in some of these movies or or
in you know like Business Place comedy or or
movie about a guy who's consumed by work and
business you know and who needs to you know take a
step back and and recognize the little things and
the important things about life and and to honor
the people around him not just just you know the
climb up the social and or uh you know economic
ladder and all that stuff and yeah I thought they
personified that nicely and they did a good job
of starting out in a pretty grounded place where
yeah this guy is a bit of a mess he's you know
got at least time management problems he's he's
a bit of a you know he's got clutter all around
and he's you know still holding down this high
level architect like it is funny like I get what
people are are pointing out when they laugh about
you know these tropes of Adam Sandler movies in
that like yeah he's this schlubby kind of wise
ass dude who somehow manages to have like the
most gorgeous wife ever always this time K back
in sale who I really liked in this too I mean I
I feel like those are characters that can fall by
the wayside or you know not I mean it's not like
she gets a million moments to really explore this
character and you know really unpack her life but
as where this character is positioned I thought
she brought a lot of just love lovely presence
to it and I really believed her and you've got
to you know kind of immediately love this person
and want to see the best for them along with the
kids kids are easier because they're cute um
but yeah you got to really kind of feel for
his family and you got to be able to feel for
her when she's going through the different you
know trials that this dude presents her kind of
constantly and yeah the way that sort of all that
compiles the transition into the Beyond section
which again like I thought that was it was fun
like I don't think they're trying too hard to
trick you like it's in the editing it's in the
way the the quality of the picture changes when he
rolls over on the bed and the colors are a little
different the lighting's a little different he
goes into the Beyond section and obviously it has
this heightened again everything's just bigger
on the inside you know like it's clearly a bit
Whimsical and Fantastical and I don't think
that they're really trying to they're I don't
think they're trying to sell it like it's not a
dream I think they're just counting on the fact
that you'll eventually forget about that and I
kind of did you know like eventually they cut
back and you're like okay yeah that's right um
but yeah I thought that was a nice conceit and
a good way to again honor the fact that this is
a bit of a it's funny I just watched The Mask
which almost had this there are elements of that
in in a different way that were reminding me or
hearkening toward It's a Wonderful Life and then
here you know I was thinking very much of of yeah
some kind of Scrooge scenario um and especially
again because it's this guy who is there are a
bunch of different ways to do this but this takes
the scope of you know a guy who is just dedicated
to his business to his job to a fault and again
that's something that I think is very relatable
where people are like I I just I got to go hard on
this because you know one more one more one more
and then we'll be able to rest and then I'll have
an assistant who can handle half this stuff and
then we will have the time then we will have the
time later and that's a really hard thing and like
you know being in an independent operation like
a YouTube channel often puts you into positions
like that and and we are lucky enough here to be
in positions where we don't have to be as like
you know immediately on top of stuff and like
rushing around and like on call all the time
but there's still that you know that persistent
I think across life no matter where you work or
or you find your you know living being made there
is that Hazard of you know worrying that it's all
going to go away and that you know if you don't
do what you're doing now you're going to you know
lose it all or it's going to decrease or or uh
you know uh uh flail in some way because of that
you know I think that's a very easy place to get
to and and the fact that you need to sacrifice
and we live in a culture that incentivizes you
to Priority that kind of equates all of your
worth and value into your job and how productive
you are and you know how your ability to pay for
things and conduct money efficiently you know
like it's it is the irony of like any piece
of especially big scale corporate art telling you
to you know step back look at what's important be
with your family when this is in and of itself
like a giant product that you know a bunch of
people probably worked insane hours to make so
like there's a ton of irony in these kinds of
stories or or like a Christopher Robin came to
mind early on in the movie and that's another
one of those where it's like thanks Disney like
like it it works in isolation I like that movie
even but yeah it's always that funny thing of like
okay massive business Corp who like half of this
half of these characters basically are the people
working in places like that who aren't taking this
advice but that also are putting out a movie with
this message you know it's it's kind of fun and
ironic but um but yeah I I liked the overall cast
and there like so many recognizable faces I feel
like we're getting to that point this is like
2006 right so we're getting to that point past
that early Heyday of like you know Sandler joints
when he was probably what fresh off the SNL cast
now we're more into like well- ingrained Adam
Sandler big screen presence uh you know again
we're solidifying the tropes of the Adam Sandler
movie and I like some of those things and other
of those things you know you feel the kind of
the wear and the stretch marks of time you know
moments where you're like okay this this hasn't
maybe aged quite as well or this sensibility maybe
doesn't fly as uh brazenly as it does you know
in a in a Time such as this you know that stuff
doesn't fly as much now you know you get to the
the harassment seminar I was like oh God what way
is this going to go and you know it's relatively
innocuous but it is still kind of like different
from the sensibility with which we approach those
things these days um and you know you have like
the Rachel Dr character transitioning into being
man uh which thankfully the movie doesn't spend
too much time on and isn't too disrespectful about
even though it is ultimately played for a joke and
it is supposed to be some kind of like what is
happening kind of thing um but also it's not so
much that you can't just be like well maybe she's
maybe he's happier like this and and we're good
at that you know we're good with that I don't
know like yeah I don't that's me filling in the
blank more than it is the movie so and and just
the the you know barrage of like you know oh we
got all these sexy assistants around and you know
women be throwing themselves at Adam Sandler and
and and the wife's sister is you know she just
sleeping with everybody's brother you know like
there there are certain things like that that
are uh you know a bit crude and a bit maybe less
socially enlightened than we like to be these
days um and you know they are what they are you
can't change them now in the past can't click that
remote and go back but as far as those elements go
those elements that usually kind of turn me off
the more crude and crass and the more not to not
to you know I don't want to launch a war in the
comments but you know the humor that skews more
misogynists certainly uh maybe not in like a mean
or malicious way but certainly plays into those
stereotypes you know those elements are here I
don't love them but they also didn't wreck the
overall impact of the movie and the scenes that
really do have their heart in a good place and you
know for again that slacker you know almost Stoner
kind of person you know I could see this being
very touching as well you know this kind of speaks
broad if you can tap into it for some of us if you
can see past the crudeness or if the crudeness
is your inroad either way you're kind of winding
up at the message at the end and and the movie
giving again way to the more um just thoughtful
and you know harder hitting themes uh yeah I I
liked the Journey of that going from yeah this
fun innocuous slacker comedy ooh fantasy element
we got this remote that could do everything but
then slowly it's you know reading your mind and
and again enhancing and amplifying your uh you
know your your core Tendencies your ID almost
and you know in doing so it's highlighting the
way in which yeah like a lot you know we all go
on autopilot we all want to check out of certain
things and it's basically telling you that you
should be present for every and yeah at the end
that culminates in good things fun things you know
he wants to tell his uh parents that he loves them
he wants to spend that time with the kids and the
family you know um but two I mean it's it's also
about yeah you got to take the showers and sit in
the traffic and have the arguments and freaking
give them Mass everybody's so averse to giving
massages and and like warming things up in the
bedroom and I'm like why guys like geez again and
it's part of the the the goofiness of the of the
plot and all that but I feel like you know I don't
yeah it's just like you're trying to fast forward
through this part to get to the already you know
the the briefest most good part I guess to you but
also yeah I don't know I'm just like how did you
guys like is this always like there's that whole
frequent joke of like oh it's so short you know
and I'm like but was it ever long if this is your
attit anyway uh yeah and then those things slowly
picking up to the point where it's like oh I can't
stop it the thing is anticipating uh my thoughts
and my you know inclinations and it knows what I
want to skip and and you know life can feel that
way like it's like time is outside your control
certainly and that you know it's rocketing by and
you're blinking and you're waking up you know many
months later and you know obviously not one to one
you've got all your memories you know you're there
every day and there's a mundanity that comes with
that but it is possible like time is a tricky and
a strange thing and it moves fast and slow all at
once and uh and I thought this in in more subtle
ways kind spoke to that and it's this the fear
the horror element that kind of sets in over time
as you're like oh my God you know I don't have
control over this now you know there are lapses
in my memory and I'm sort of coming to and and you
know it's almost like you're it's almost like the
story of someone disassociating if you removed
the Sci-Fi element of you know the remote and
all the fun stuff like I thought it was really fun
what they did with the you know like the construct
and and checking in on the rules and like okay
so you're kind of in an autopilot like a really
lowgrade autopilot when you're fast forwarding or
skipping chapters and I mean I guess it's lucky
that you know this guy's paths that that he was
on in autopilot basically led him to like huge
you know again economic success um but it does
it is just like a funny thing to me I'm I'm like
okay interesting like you know because it could
go so wrong in so many ways on autopilot when
you're skipping ahead like I I have to imagine
it's like he he thinks about what he wants and
he gets there so it's also a manifestation
mie uh but but you know like what if you got
3 years later to the point you thought you'd get
your promotion and find yourself like out on the
street or something you know but but those are
things that I wasn't really thinking about during
the movie and those are just things that yeah you
you can Muse about within the high concept of it
you know but for again a high concept comedy like
this that a doesn't have to get very emotional if
it doesn't want to and B doesn't have to develop
the scii you know doesn't have to develop the high
concept doesn't have to develop the rules of the
world or whatever I thought they did a fun job of
paying attention to those things and you know
playing with time subtly so that you know when
you're further into his life you know the set
designs are really different and you're in like
a future hospital at the end and like the hair uh
cuts are changing and the outfits are changing and
getting more you know sort of out there and more
futurized and everything and the makeups too like
there are old age makeups there are younger age
makeups for some of the older actors I thought
all that stuff was nice uh you know the the
fat suits like again for for some of the more
uh Progressive and inclusive uh conversations we
have you know developed in our culture you know
since this came out you know like it's you know
you're you're using that the the bigger body for
a punchline which is kind of a drag but it also
does factor into the story to some degree again
like those are things that if you really wanted
to like flesh those threads out and be like oh man
like you know this again Adam Sandler is able to
like skate through this movie having like a fine
enough physique whilst also like always eating
candy so like I was like if you done this maybe
a little more gradually but you know again there's
that effect of like well when he wakes up that way
and it's like totally foreign you know like I I
get the choices they made here if it was my movie
I might have uh you know finessed them a little
better or um I don't know just done it in a way
that doesn't punch down quite as hard um but you
know again for for the sensibility of what this
is it's not to be unexpected really and I thought
that yeah the the the greater Strokes of the movie
and you know the message behind it and just the
way that it's characterized and The Ensemble they
drew together was quite charming and yeah by the
end like this did transcend from being just a fun
Whimsical uh again sort of uh off uh not off the
cuff but but yeah that sort of like um what is
I don't know what to call that demeanor but that
you know that ribbing sort of demeanor that sort
of uh that very um like big brother kind of noie
demeanor where like yeah you know like it it's
it's busting a lot of balls and stuff like that
but I bought the you know actual sentimental side
and I feel like we're also kind of witnessing
that transition from you know more broad comedy
for Sandler into you know starting to to play
with drama because you know when you get to the
end there again like when he's uh saying when he's
replaying the moment of his father saying I love
you son and and you know looking at him that way
and even when uh he's got the the bit later on uh
or no no it's just before that with with his son
but but then yeah later on when he wants you know
his son not to make the mistakes that he did and
and you know to go on the honeymoon instead of
staying back and working on this project that's in
shambles or whatever you know like those moments I
bought the commitment and the emotion and all that
too and so like the sweet things that are supposed
to tug at your heartstrings ultimately work and so
do the cautionary things and I think that's I I'm
starting to see that that's kind of the magic
when it's working of an Adam Sandler movie you
know it's the heart that arises despite you know
the more abrasive parts of the main character
often attitude um sometimes it's characters
around them like if you're watching the water
boy or something like that you know um Bobby buet
is like a he a very endearing and sweet character
whereas I'm more used to seeing Adam Sandler play
guys like this who are again a bit of a wise ass
and who are you know real ball busters and stuff
like that you know he's a kind of a GU guy uh so
yeah like those elements are here and sometimes
they're funny uh and the rest of it you know it I
don't know it's it's attuned well enough that when
you suspend disbelief for you know what we know as
the Sandler verse kind of uh yeah like this is an
example of a movie that I thought tied together
quite nicely and that worked and that you know
showcased a good amount of heart and a thoughtful
story I could tell like again I I I hesitate to
say that Adam Sandler I I hesitate T to use the
word mature or maturing maturity but it does have
a more mature quality to it or it's aspiring to
something more mature uh you know whilst also
having like a bunch of humping dog jokes and
stuff like that but you know uh again for what
this is and for who it's playing to you know
this it's again the kind of Comedy that I don't
put at the top of my taste scale but at the same
time I can tap into when it's good and when again
there are you know other elements around be they
good casting an interesting concept some heart uh
again a little bit of you know World weariness or
whatever that is and I thought this tied together
very nicely into all of that while also taking
time to have a a good sense of Attunement with its
fantasy and yeah I found it overall to be really
fun and Charming so uh those are my thoughts on
click uh let me know your thoughts as well good
soundtrack on this too um and yeah a lot of nice
little character beats in between the the more
Broad and and crass elements so uh so yeah
I think there's a lot for a lot of different
people to grab from this and again just a great
High concept jumping off point in the universal
remote and all that stuff uh so yeah that's what I
got for now leave me your thoughts down below stay
tuned for whatever comes next leave me whatever
other Adam Sandler joins you want uh one or any
of us to check out and uh yeah we'll catch you
on the next one much love for now people and uh
cheers